la santé encore remuer vous bougez vous
c'est le thème d'une campagne lancée
aujourd'hui par les services de la santé
pour inciter les français à faire de
l'exercice
20 millions de personnes souffrent d'un
excès de poids c'est aussi une
explication du déficit de la sécu
isabelle quintard nathalie gal regardez
bien en quelques minutes
toutes ces personnes vont choisir
systématiquement l'escalator et vous des
l'escalier pourtant juste à côté et tout
le monde a bien sûr les meilleures
raisons du monde pour cela parce que
j'ai une rude journée
ce jeu là c'est parce que je suis avec
ma collègue que d'habitude franchement
prend les escaliers
un exemple parmi d'autres d'un mal
moderne la sédentarité le ministère de
la santé a donc décidé de lancer une
campagne d'information pour nous inciter
à être plus actifs
ne perdons pas l'envié de bouger en
grandissant l'idéal vanté par ce spot
télévisé faire au moins 30 minutes de
marche par jour
un petit exercice avec de grands effets
sur la santé
ça prévient la prise de poids avec les
années ça prévient le stress à retard de
même ça a été prouvé par des études
récentes l'apparition du diabète de type
2 qui est également un véritable fléau
ça améliore les taux de cholestérol et
en particulier le bon cholestérol mais
comment faire lorsqu'on est citadin est
toujours pressé on peut peut-être
privilégié l'escalier laisser la voiture
au garage sortir le chien plus longtemps
ou descendre du bus ou du métro un peu
plus tôt et puis chacun de choisir son
sport plus ou moins violents
avant je faisais du vélo maintenant je
cite la lacc
c'est moins dur la pétanque c'est encore
de l'activité physique est donc un moyen
de lutter contre le surpoids et
l'obésité qui concerne plus de 5
millions d'adultes en france